welcome to all of you my name is Larry
yarn I work at the college and I want to
give you a special welcome and I want to
say thanks for something great done for
us lately that affects this event the
AWC foundation in Nashville led by
Andrea wait Carlton and Steve Rasmussen
actually administers the foundation have
given an endowment gift so that we can
have these lectures and that means stock
market behaving in the world not
collapsing they'll probably go on for a
long time that's a great gift probably
some of the speakers will be invited to
go down to Nashville where they live
because they want to meet the speakers
and also share them with their neighbors
down there in Nashville and Andrea and
Steve will probably be up here sometimes
and we look forward to walking them at
the kirby center and they're going to
watch the tape of this thank you very
very much andrea is a tremendous person
very smart Full Faith very tough just
the kind we like the lectures are
important because they're what we do we
hold of you here at the college that
we're in the middle of a great debate
enormous choices choices of universal
significance are pending in the country
the meaning of America is so clear it is
the most coherently founded country in
all of history it has a birthday the
birthday begins with a document that
explains what the country is all about
and today there's an argument about that
today we have new purposes and those new
purposes which have transformed the
government it's a different looking
thing than it used to be a different
functioning thing different entirely and
stay in size and scope and it too has
reasons
and those reasons can be looked up you
can find them for example in our
Constitution reader published by
hillsdale college at reasonable cost and
all of the great tracts that justify the
modern liberal bureaucratic state are
reproduced their examples of the highest
and most important reasoning that led us
where we are and that reasoning goes on
today all the time not always well I
David Bob lately pointed me to a
publication of the what's it called the
Center for American Progress where they
associate modern liberalism with
Alexander Hamilton especially and with
the founders and this piece of writing
is articulate and good and thank God for
the existence of it I argue that it just
needs one more thing to be entirely
persuasive it needs to be true and and
in that great we can have a discussion
about that because of course the things
I'm saying right now if they become
known to those people they're going to
argue that there's just one thing about
what I'm saying and that is it needs to
be true and that raises the question
which is true and that is the choice now
we in this room nor any small group of
people however motivated however
diligent however whys are not according
to the principles of the United States
empowered to make that's the choice we
do not get to make the choice we ought
not to make the choice and ought not to
think that we can that is a choice for
the American people our function is to
equip them to make the choice by trying
to make the argument as good as it can
be as clear as it can be and of course
that begins with what happens right here
in this room and also what happens in
those classrooms at that gaggle of boys
and girls sitting right over there have
to go back to in August where they will
be tortured until they understand
and there's just a few of us in this
room and there's just a few of us in
those classrooms and that is very
important because that contributes to
the purity and excellence of what goes
on in those places but on the other hand
we are blessed at the college to have
the means to make that activity radiate
and it does go everywhere we have a
publication that goes to close to three
million people every month it's the
craziest thing on earth to do and we've
been doing that crazy thing now for 40
years more than 40 years and we have now
several hundred thousand people taking
online courses with the college and they
are interested in what it has to teach
and of course what it has to teach is an
invitation into an argument and
understanding the basis of the argument
on the various sides we actually think
that that is the process that will save
the United States of America and its
Republic we think that for example the
lincoln-douglas debates which were hotly
contested revealed a great truth on
which the nation was able finally to act
with tragic violence and ultimate
success that is the process we're going
to engage in it today I'm not going to
introduce our speaker although I'm a
great fan of hers because she's wise and
faithful and learned in the law and she
does a tremendous good work in the city
and elsewhere I I want her to know that
I'm personally glad that she is here and
I want to ask Jackie Frankel to come up
please and introduce her
cleta Mitchell is a partner in the
Washington DC office of foley & lardner
LLP and a member of the firm's political
law practice she received her BA and her
JD from the University of Oklahoma and
served from nineteen seventy six to
nineteen eighty four as a member of the
Oklahoma House of Representatives she
serves on the boards of directors of the
National Rifle Association and the Lynde
and Harry Bradley Foundation is chairman
of the American Conservative Union
foundation and has served as president
of the Republican National Lawyers
Association she is currently
representing several conservative groups
singled out for scrutiny by the IRS
please join me in welcoming cleta
Mitchell
well hello to all of you and thank you
for being here today I love to be in
this room which is reminiscent of the
constitutional convention in
Philadelphia and constitution hall it is
a reminder of what it is we're all about
in this country and so we're very
grateful I'm very grateful to Hillsdale
College to dr. Bob for inviting me and
to all that you do here in this space
it's quite a wonderful thing that you've
done in a very short and remarkable
thing you've done in a pretty short
period of time here in Washington I want
to talk about you know we hear about the
IRS scandal I want to tell you and dr.
Arden is still back there so thank you
appreciate it thank you I want to tell
you kind of how this came to my
attention how it came to be people ask
me what I do for a living and I tell
them I am the consigliere to the vast
right-wing conspiracy that's what I do i
represent candidates and campaigns and
party committees republican party
committees I represent issue
organizations and i represent donors and
corporations all if you have to
understand that politics and policy in
this country is a very highly regulated
business it always pains me because I
think did we just completely forget what
the founders wrote in the first five
words of the First Amendment what George
will says are the five most beautiful
words in the English language Congress
shall make no law but the fact of the
matter is it's highly regulated at the
state and federal level so people come
to me they want to do things and I say
okay let's see what based on what you
want to do this is where you fit into
the legal system and the very first
thing you have to do when somebody says
I want to do a group of us we want to do
X you want to start anything in America
at least in the legal side of the
marketplace I don't know how people
function in the black market and under
the radar that's just beyond my
understanding but the first thing you
have to do is you
to get a bank account right to get a
bank account you have to have a number
everybody in America has a number again
if you're legal that all of us have
social security numbers that's the
number we give the bank that's the
number that is on our tax return if you
want to form an entity if you form an
LLC or a partnership or any other
anything you your accountant or you will
file a form and you'll check a box and
you'll say this is the kind of entity we
want to be and then that artificial
entity doesn't have a social security
number it gets what's known as an
employer ID number and ein it's the
first step toward doing any Enterprise
in America there except for one set
within the tax code the tax code defines
everything in America interestingly
enough and you have to tell we're in the
tax code you fit if you're going to be a
tax-exempt organization however you're
the only [ __ ] the only kind of entity
that has to get permission from the
government why because contributions are
not taxable as income that's what that
means tax-exempt organizations pay a lot
of taxes they pay Social Security taxes
like payroll taxes they pay sales taxes
some of them pay property taxes they
just don't have to pay taxes on their
contributions that's all tax that tax
exempt means but the IRS gets to say you
have to do mother may I may I be
recognized as a tax exempt organization
everybody else you want to form a
partnership and LLC you just check the
box and going down the road you do not
have to ask for permission from the
government you file a tax return
according to what kind of entity you are
so I've been doing this for a long time
historically prior to 2009 will say I
think that there might be some
correlation between some other things
that happened in America in 2009 but I
would I would fill out an application
for a client a group of people who
wanted to be a grassroots lobbying
organization a 501 C 4 social welfare
group it would take maybe five weeks
maybe six weeks to get a 501 C 3
designation
as a charitable educational organization
that would take a little bit longer
maybe two months maybe three months and
mainly because contributions to those
kinds of entities are deductible as
charitable contributions the IRS thinks
it's their money they don't want to give
that money up easily so they ask you a
few more questions but and when we got
questions if you got questions back from
the IRS what you would get would be
questions related to the actual
application the thing that I want it's
my first point I want everybody to
understand what got the IRS into this
mess in the first place is something
that is fundamental to our American Way
of life and that is the rule of law we
operate have for hundreds of years now
operated under a principle that the rule
of law means that all of us as citizens
are entitled to know what the law is
what's the government what can it do and
not do how and to be judged equally
based on what the law says and not who
we are the rule of law is that we are a
nation of laws not of men and women it
is that there are objective legal
standards every agency of the government
must treat us in accordance with those
standards what happened with the IRS
beginning in 2009 we know it started in
2010 I think it really started in 2009
was that they started taking certain
treating certain citizens certain
taxpayers every organization that's
subjected to this horrible screening and
targeting is a taxpayer that's their
defined legally as a taxpayer and they
took certain taxpayers based on their
beliefs based on their philosophy based
on the kinds of things in which they
wish to engage which involved
criticizing their government let's not
forget that that's the number one thing
that these groups wanted to be able to
do was criticized their government and
they took those taxpayers hundreds of
them and instead of following the rule
of law and the very specific multi-page
application to become a 501 C 3 in a
multi-page application hundreds of
questions lots of schedules to become a
501 C 4 and they took those people those
taxpayers and they treated them they
said we're going to treat you
differently we're going to ask you
things that have nothing to do with
what's on the published application
we're going to give you questions and
delay your application and really
basically intimidate you and that they
departed from the rule of law so I had
an organization my first inkling that
something had changed was in the fall of
2009 I had an organization that came to
me and they wanted just to do grassroots
organizing against Obamacare I want you
to think back what was happening 2009
the fall 2009 remember december two
thousand nine scott brown is elected
that didn't stop those people the
people's will never seems to matter to
them january-february it was Obamacare
it was the bailout it was the stimulus
package all in 2009 stall that's what
the gave rise to the Tea Party movement
and I think that they decided that they
needed to try they being the officials
at the IRS and people in power in
Washington that they needed to try to do
something to put the brakes on this
effort to criticize and stop Obamacare
and the other things that these groups
said they wanted to try to do which was
to stop all of this so we applied in
October of 2009 for this group that
wanted to just be involved in lobbying
against Obamacare and that is all they
did they lobbied for the extension of
the Bush tax cuts a year later but they
were not involved in any political
activity at all and I didn't hear
anything in the rest of 2009 usually
remember five weeks max maybe six weeks
nothing in all of the spring of 2010
and the first word that I had from the
IRS about this organization was in June
of 2010 and they asked for copies of all
of the ads that had been run by this
group against Obamacare and I called the
IRS agent I refer to them as our parole
officer since I have to check in with
them periodically and I said I said well
this is really unusual I said I but is
this about and he let me tell you the
interesting interesting things about
this this agent and this application for
this group was never in Cincinnati it
was I was dealing with the Washington
office of the IRS from day one which was
odd and then when I said to him what is
this about you want all the ads that
this group has run against Obamacare and
he said yes and I said what's that about
he said I want you to understand
something there are people here who do
not understand the difference between a
501c3 that can only do a little bit of
lobbying and a 501 C 4 that can spend
all of its money on lobbying all of it
that organization I provided that in
July of 2010 in June of 2011 I wrote
them a letter i said i have heard
nothing from you for a year the only
thing that this organization has done
was to lobby against obamacare i'm
beginning to think the only reason it
hasn't been granted it's exempt status
is because it has opposed this
administration I would find that very
disturbing within three days I got a
call from three agents on a conference
call calling did assure me that that was
not the case and I said well where's our
letter of exempt status it's been almost
two years that organization we didn't
hear anything else from the IRS until
the spring of last year and we got one
of those letters that they sent to
hundreds and hundreds of organizations
across the country that had hundreds of
questions there were something like 40
questions each one has
five parts subparts asking for donors
who are your donors of two thousand
dollars or more which there's no legal
authority for asking for that kind of
information there's a whole different
process for that they ask who have you
associated with how many meetings have
you had we want a list of every meeting
you've had and everyone who's attended
every meeting you've had they asked for
true the vote for Catherine Engelbrecht
they asked every place she had spoken in
the last two years who she spoke to and
everybody in the audience it would be
like asking me two years from now to say
who of you had attended this meeting at
Hillsdale asking are you or any member
of your board going to run for office
have you or any of your family members
contemplated contemplated running for
office I took I mean I had already been
having this fight with the IRS over
three or four of my clients who had
applied for exempt status and nothing
had happened when we got those letters
from the IRS I put them in a packet I
redacted the names and I headed to
Capitol Hill to see the staffers the
house ways and means and the Senate
Finance Committee and I said guys
something is going on at the IRS this is
totally out of the norm there they have
they're asking questions and doing
things in there up there with holding
the application for exempt status for no
reason so fast forward of course the IRS
Commissioner was called over to testify
before Congress doug shulman in March of
2012 and was asked and several letters
were sent to the IRS and I had given a
list of questions to yeah so here's some
questions to the staffers that they
could ask the IRS which they did and the
IRS is the spring of last year March of
last year said there is no targeting
doug shulman told congress there's no
tar
getting of conservative groups none
whatsoever and they've refused to answer
it they didn't provide any of the
responses to any of the other questions
that had been sent other than to say
nothing is happening you know you're
you're totally fabricating this you guys
need to do something else with your
lives and what we know what we know for
certain is that as early as August of
2011 that the Washington office the IRS
chief counsel's office was involved in
developing what ultimately became the
template for those onerous burden some
questionnaires that were sent I had one
client we submitted two volumes of
paperwork in response to just one of the
requests they asked for every some
things you just said well we don't have
any way to provide that they asked for
every Facebook posting they asked for a
print out of every page of the website
since inception you know make them and
the thing that's really frustrating is
that so many of these groups are really
small mom-and-pop organizations who
literally were found you know for their
annual income was probably less than
five thousand dollars you know so fast
forward to this year we know that they
were very involved and knew everybody in
the c-suite or the in the commissioners
floor at the IRS they they knew within
weeks if they hadn't known before they
certainly knew within weeks of Shulman's
testimony that it was false now I keep
wondering why it is that he gets to lie
to Congress with impunity and then I
remember oh that would have to be
enforced by Eric Holder and the Justice
Department I mean but ask Roger Clemens
what happens if you lie to Congress it
hasn't happened to Doug Shulman but it
should he should be prosecuted because
he lied to Congress and it is a felony
to lie to Congress it's not a felony for
them to lie to us by the
it just it's just a felony to lie to
them if you're testifying so fast
forward to this year so Lois Lerner who
is the head of the exempt organizations
unit or was at the time every year she
speaks to a meeting of the tax-exempt
section of the American Bar Association
every and the meeting is held every year
the second week of second Friday of May
in Washington and this year she did not
speak but she spoke in person but she
spoke by phone on a conference call and
she planted a question in the audience a
friend somebody who's written a lot in
this arena and wrote a question had her
ask the question about targeting
conservative groups to which Lois Lerner
response as follows she says oh yes we
found out about that it was a couple of
rogue agents in Cincinnati and we fixed
it and thus began the lie after lie
after lie of the IRS every statement the
IRS has made since this became public
and before has been false and now
apparently our job is just to keep
proving how everything they say is a lie
I believe and I have confirmed with
people who work inside worked inside the
Commissioner's Office they really
believed they had this was a strategy
they really believed that she would say
that on a Friday afternoon and that it
was old news by Monday because guess
what that has been the experience with
every one of these other scandals of
this administration so why would they
think that the press would actually take
one of these things seriously that we're
concerned about and they were completely
flummoxed and shocked that the reaction
to this yes we did target conservatives
was so strong and vehement in the
mainstream press and I have to tell you
I was a little surprised too and I kept
saying we need to get as much as we
can out of this because at one at some
point the press is going to start
remembering that they hate us and that
it's really okay that this happened and
guess what what is happening by if you
figure this happened on Friday on Monday
when there was just this whirlwind of
stories and shock and outrage so Stephen
Miller the acting commissioner what does
he deal on Monday after Lois's little
thing on Friday he writes an op-ed
that's published on Tuesday in USA Today
in which he basically denies that
anything bad has happened except that on
Wednesday the treasure inspector general
for tax administration TIG to the tikati
report was released which documented
over nearly three hundred groups that we
know of that were targeted and we've
gone from there I want you there are
five things I really want you to because
I want to leave time for questions but
there are five things I really want you
to take away and I have a handout if you
don't have it now you can pick it up on
the way out but things that I really
want you to understand about this
scandal number one is what I said
earlier this is a departure from the
rule of law this is what happens in a
banana republic this is what happened in
the former Soviet Union this is what
happens in a totalitarian regime it is
when a bunch of bureaucrats or
commissars behind closed doors decide
how they're going to what law it is
they're going to create out of whole
cloth and how they're going to treat
citizens and punish them or withhold
government favor etc etc this scandal is
writ large one of the most troubling
things to me about the Obama
administration because we can we've seen
it over and over and over again but it
is particularly acute when we're talking
about this particular scandal every we
all understand the IRS it reaches into
every one of our lives you can't do
anything you can't open a bank account
unless you got a number from
the IRS start with that so they departed
from the rule of law it's fundamental to
our society and we cannot let them get
away with this number two that the
official position of the IRS regarding
the scandal every single statement they
have made has been proven to be false
they started out to rogue agents in
Cincinnati I fired off a letter on the
Friday afternoon after Louis made her
comments because I had been go I meet
monthly with a group of lawyers who do
what I do right and left you know this
is the one time conservative and the
lawyers for conservative groups lawyers
for liberal groups we meet once a month
and we just talk about things like the
FEC and the IRS and alphabet soup of
these agencies and how it affects all of
our clients regardless of what their
purpose or mission is and i had taken
copies of these redacted letters a year
ago when they first came out to the
lunch and handed them out to all the
attorneys including the liberal
attorneys and i said if any of your
groups gotten any of this of course they
never have they never seen any of that
they all thought I was crazy but let me
tell you what when Louis made her
comments a number of them were there and
they immediately started sending me
emails I didn't I wasn't there and they
started sending me emails saying oh my
gosh cleta was right we thought you were
just crazy but you're really right I
said well just because we're paranoid
doesn't mean when they're not out to get
us but so I fired off a letter to Lois
Lerner and Steven Miller that afternoon
saying do not issue an apology issue my
clients letters a determination of
exempt status we've been waiting for
years and we know and I said and for you
to say that this was two rogue agents in
Cincinnati is a complete lie because I
knew that another one of my clients in
November of tooth in October of 2011
when I talked to the parole officer in
Cincinnati he said you know lady these
decisions are all being made in
Washington and I had memorialized that
in writing in November of 2011 so I knew
that she was lying
when they say that that it's over that's
the third thing this is not in the past
tense it's still going on I have clients
I have one client that I can actually
share because he gave me permission it's
how I first came to know dr. Bob and
hillsdale college a group of people
wanted to organize something called the
Constitutional Congress to help new
members of Congress study the
Constitution and understand their
constitutional imperatives that
application was filed in March of 2011
we have heard nothing from the IRS until
may of 2013 right after the scandal
broke and now it's what almost it's then
almost into July we've heard nothing and
guess what that that organization when
we heard from the IRS guess what they
wanted to know what materials are you
going to be using what copyrights exist
for those materials you know I you know
kid please provide copies of the
materials that you plan to use so i just
sent them back a copy of the
Constitution and I said to my na LAN die
gave them links to websites and starting
with hillsdale's quite wonderful website
on the study of the Constitution I said
there are a number of universities and
organizations that make these materials
available free of charge because they
want the American people to study the
Constitution but you'd think that having
submitted that the end of May it
wouldn't be too hard to say okay fine
here's your letter I've heard nothing so
it's still going on and then what they
did then what they did which it is so
infuriating is that earlier this month
the acting commissioner of the IRS
Daniel Werfel said oh we've come up with
a solution we're going to ask all of
these targeted groups actually learn the
other day only 82 of them were subset
these letters I don't know what's
supposed to be going on with the rest of
these people
you didn't get the letter saying if you
will make a deal with the government if
you'll make a deal with us that you will
promise under penalty of perjury that
you will not engage in political
activities and expenditures in excess of
forty percent including not just your
expenditures but volunteer activities
then we'll give you your exempt status
letter and again I come back to where's
the authority and the law for that
there's no legal authority for that and
better yet how many liberal groups have
had to make that promise if the unions
would make that promise I might think
about it but it's really it's again it's
making it up as they go along it's
departing from the rule of law and
treating people differently in our
country based on their viewpoint their
political or philosophical viewpoint it
is an outrage and then i would say
finally the democrats and on the
congressional committees I mean it's
really hard for me to watch these
hearings but I have to but they
perpetuated several myths one is that
the progressive groups were subject to
the same scrutiny as near as we can tell
there were maybe seven progressive
groups who were who were reviewed for
additional who pulled for additional
scrutiny it's like going fishing you
know you catch it look at it throw it
back in well that's what happened the
progressive groups none of them got the
same kind of oppressive letters none of
them are still being having their
tax-exempt status held up now they also
you know most of the reason that they
say this happens because of citizens
united I don't know if you knew but
citizens united I think causes cancer
because actually citizens united is
responsible for about every bad thing
that could possibly have happened in the
United States and since january twenty
ten most of these Tea Party groups as I
said they're tiny little groups they're
not they're not Karl Rove they're
they're tiny little groups and they are
planning to run ads and they didn't form
to be a c4 because of citizens united
and they didn't you know they say well
there was just a huge influx of
applications really if you look at the
statue you look at the numbers the
statistics citizens united was handed
down in January 2010 they say over there
was this big influx there were actually
fewer applications for exempt status for
C 4 organizations in 2010 than in 2009
and then they say you know they're
trying to say that 501 c 4 groups should
not be allowed to have make any
political expenditures I figure that the
left-wing 501 C force will put a stop to
that although they always try to find a
way to catch our guys and they keep
operating with impunity actually that's
true i mean you know the fact is they
could pass that law and then they would
just ignore it and our we would be the
ones who abide by the law but you know
the main thing i hope that happens next
is that you know the IRS is doing
everything it can do to to stall to not
answer questions they send back
documents are so heavily redacted that
you can't even understand what the
meaning of the document is they are
using I'll close with this one thing I
want to be sure NAT plenty of time for
questions but after Watergate Congress
passed a law to say that section 6103 of
the tax code to say that it was illegal
for any taxpayers confidential
information to be inspected or dis or
release disseminated that was to make
sure that whatever we send to the IRS is
confidential and if you're an IRS
employee you're not supposed to just go
perusing somebody's information without
authorization the IRS is now using that
statute as a shield to protect the IRS
employees who have been involved in the
scandal and saying that they cannot
release information about the scandal
and a
out individual situations because it
would violate section 6103 and i'll give
you the classic example it's something
out of Kafka I represent the National
Organization for Marriage about a year
ago we realized that the huffington post
it published our schedule be our
confidential schedule of donors the IRS
requires that on an organization's Form
990 tax information return that's filed
every year one of the schedules is a
schedule that lists the donors who
contributed $5,000 or more that is not
what you have to disclose that to the
IRS it is not it is not a publicly the
statute also says that you can you can
read act the name and address of the
donor for your public inspection copy
because you have to make your 990
available to anyone who asked for it but
you don't have to tell them you don't
have to have in your public inspection
copy the list of who your donors are the
IRS has it but not the public so the
Huffington Post is published noms 2008
form 990 scheduled be with all of its
donors and through some technological
wizardry that I can't don't begin to
understand our technology person or noms
technology person was able to peel off
something that they had put on it
somehow and show that it was the every
document that's filed with the IRS is
coded and it had the official coding we
know that it was the as filed at 990
form we immediately wrote a letter to
the Treasury Inspector General demanding
an investigation and then we know that
the Treasury Inspector General came out
interviewed the people at non asked from
materials we provided that and then we
heard nothing so about three months
later we sent a letter saying what's
happening they said we can't tell you
we said why can't you tell us because
6103 protects the confidentiality the
taxpayers confidentiality we sit were
the taxpayer we have not been able to
get anything we finally filed a FOIA
request and they sent us copies of
things that we had filed asking for the
investigation and asked and asking where
is that where the results of the
investigation that's their idea of
freedom of information and so we're
preparing to file that suit against the
IRS for violation of 6103 but one of the
things that's happening is that the IRS
is using that same process and hiding
behind that same statute to keep from
having to provide information to the
House Ways and Means Committee and to
the government oversight and Reform
Committee in conducting this
investigation i think friday the house
ways and means committee issued a
statement in a pie chart the IRS says
that it has x million documents
responsive or Purton to this
investigation they were they've released
like point three percent to date and
those are very heavily redacted so you
know I think the president this
administration is hoping that willow
lose sight of this lose interest the
media will go on down the road the IRS
can stall and keep anybody from paying
attention to this I'm hoping like crazy
that that doesn't happen but but it's
tough and we have a slope we have slow
going but it's so important that we not
let this go unanswered and that the
people be held accountable and the final
thing is i will say then i'll be happy
to answer questions of values that i do
represent true the vote as well we have
filed suit in federal court here in DC
we're preparing to file suit on behalf
of nom we think that it that will be a
corollary that and there are a couple of
other cases that these lawsuits
hopefully if we can if we can keep them
in court and get the discovery and get
maybe some judicial interpretation of
6103
that it was passed to protect the
taxpayers and not the IRS that maybe we
can ultimately get to the truth so with
that I thank you I would be glad to stop
any answer questions
yes mark I think they do you have a
microphone okay you want to come over
here I cleat a great speech thank you so
much for what you're doing my question
is about whether you know anything about
the audits of Republican donors and just
let you know Martha Boneta is here
Martha is I was on Fox Greta Van
Susteren show Thursday night she was in
a dispute with her county and the
Piedmont Environmental Council she got
an IRS audit that was disclosed to ana
county official before she got notice of
the audit which under 6103 is a civil
violation potentially a felony and ten
days after she went public with her
audit her house was vandalized so these
people are very serious and what they're
doing but do you know anything about
more about the audits I'm really glad
that you mentioned that because I'm
familiar with the case Mart brought it
to my attention and thank you for what
you're doing and sorry for everything
you've been through this is you know
this citizen who has the temerity to
think that she can he use her own
property for the purposes for which she
wants to use it where did you get that
idea lady but you know one of the things
that I have been urging and I think that
I and the House Ways and Means Committee
has issued a public statement and in
fact chairman camp at the very first
Ways and Means Committee hearing said
there that they are also going to look
at and investigate the the audits the
audit division not just the exempt
organizations division but the audit
division look I mean I'm hearing stories
you can imagine I mean people are
calling me and emailing me about audits
that I think there were an inordinate
number of audits of Romney donors and
fundraisers there were audits of
conservative organizations and the thing
there
common theme that I keep hearing which
is that people will say to me my
accountant said he's been doing this for
30 years and he's never seen them behave
quite like this I hear that over and
over and over so that these agents of
the IRS are not conducting themselves in
the same way that people who are normal
who are used to dealing with them have
come to expect so that tells me that
these audits have come about in in in
not appropriate ways and you know i'm
sure you've along the lines of this
sharing of information with local
officials it happened to you it happened
also to christine o'donnell in Delaware
where information a false tax lien was
put on property she had sold a year
earlier and then all of this information
was given to the state attorney general
who's the son of Joe Biden I mean it's
really quite breathtaking and it really
does make you stop and think oh my gosh
are we really still in America it's
really quite frightening yes sir
Washington is is this idea of well
they're two different parties with you
know two different world views and
bipartisanship is good and we're taught
that in civics class growing up so we
come with that idea but yet the picture
you've painted is one radically
different it's really one of a side
that's actually mendacious and a tissue
of lies and really it sounds evil I mean
do you see it in quite that stark terms
or yes I don't I I think that I think I
do see it in those start terms because I
think that there are people who think
that look I mean if you look at true the
vote is the perfect example true the
vote is an organization from Houston
Texas that was founded in 2010 they
really can't grow out of the Tea Party
movement and there was a group of
citizens and they decided that what they
thought they could do for America is
that would Kobe poll Watchers they would
be poll observers they would
serve the election process I mean we
have three federal agencies that we pay
for we pay for to send observers to
elections all around the world I just
got a report from the International
Foundation for electoral systems last
week we just sent a team we're sending a
team to Zimbabwe and what are we look
what are they doing they're looking to
see if people are properly registered
they're looking to see if those who are
voting are eligible to vote if there is
corruption in the casting of the balance
we pay for that in Zimbabwe what it
ought to be okay for volunteers to do it
in Houston don't you think except that
what they made the mistake of doing is
they made the mistake of being really
smart and effective and so why you have
dozens of these groups on the left all
of whom have 501c3 status project vote
which is a very partisan organization
that President Obama used to work for
their a 501c3 organization true the vote
applied for its 501c3 status in July of
2010 we still don't have it we've suit
them but let me tell you what they've
done they took they created with
volunteers they created a software
package I mean these people talk about
things I don't even understand I'm Way
too old understand what they're talking
about they created with volunteer people
a software capability a functionality
where you can download the voter rolls
in any jurisdiction in America and
there's an overlay against google maps
so that you can tell whether there are
20 people registered at a vacant lot
well how wonderful is that oh no this is
considered a complete threat so guess
what happens to the president of true
the vote within a very short time within
six months after they applied for their
tax-exempt status Catherine Engelbrecht
and her husband
and had an IRS audit their company they
have a small manufacturing company IRS
audit they were visited by the Bureau of
Alcohol Tobacco and Firearms twice they
were visited by the FBI seven times they
were visited by OSHA they were visited
by the Texas Environmental Quality
Commission on a referral from the EPA
now is there anyone in this room who
thinks that that's coincidental I mean I
watch NCIS there are no coincidences so
do I think that this is evil I do I
think that there that this organization
has been targeted because it is so
effective and that they at beginning as
early as the fall of two thousand and
ten Bob Bauer who at the time was
Obama's Council to his campaigns and
counsel to the DNC d-triple-c DSCC wrote
a memo about how dangerous true the vote
was anyone over to become white House
Counsel yes yes what do you think the
chances of a select committee being
formed are well i wish i could tell you
i thought they were really good I have
recommended that to the council to the
speaker mainly because something there
needs to be some a group of people and
staff who are able to share information
and focus just on this it is too big and
too important and the IRS is trying to
do such a they're making such an effort
to deflect into symbol and delay and
deny that I think we have to figure out
how can we be more strategic in terms of
making sure we get to the bottom of this
I worry that it might be a little too
late because now the Democrats have
regrouped and we'll probably would
probably stop it there was a point in
time where they probably would have
voted to do that just because they at
the time we're still trying to pretend
like they cared about this kind of
horrible activity so i don't know i'm
not very hopeful
going forward other than in
investigating the IRS what what can an
alternative system look like that would
allow for less bureaucratic well I think
that's a really good question I
basically think that what should happen
is we should get we should just abandon
this mother may I approach why should
the government get to pass judgment on
whether or not an organization is or is
not able to operate as a grassroots
lobbying organization I mean the only
the only conceivable argument I might be
willing to have with someone might be
over 501 C 3 organizations because
contributions are tax deductible which
is not true for any of the other there
are 29 categories of 501 C groups but I
would also just argue that if you if
what you did was just let people form
and file and then they have to file a
tax information return just like you do
in business I mean you don't have to ask
the government's permission to form an
LLC you file your tax return for that
type of entity and it's subject to audit
now I do think I do think and actually
this is not my idea this is Michelle
Easton's idea from the clare boothe luce
Policy Institute which was subjected to
one of these audits she said you know I
think we'd all feel better if they did a
public lottery and just said okay you
know we're going to here's how the
audits are going to take place we're
just going to do a public lottery or
some kind of random system so that there
was literally no human judgment call
about whose subject to audit but if you
all if you know that your number could
come up then you know then you want to
make sure that you've done everything
right because then they can come in and
look at everything but I do not think
that organizations ought to have to ask
the government's permission and I don't
think there's much that we can do to try
to fix this problem by writing a bunch
more rules and regulations about what
isn't isn't political activity and
particularly when I hear the acting
commissioner I RS only have IRS agents
and I have my own experience telling me
that these people do not know the
difference between lobbying and
political those are two different
they're not interchangeable they have
separate legal definitions and they were
conflating the two and still are I have
no confidence and I think this is
protected First Amendment activity we
should not have to ask the government's
permission to engage in it yes
well I think that's a really good
question i think the difficulty we have
at the moment is that who would know
from if you see the documents they've
gotten back from the IRS they may redact
it they reject everybody's name
everybody's title so you could have
names of union officials and their
titles and who would know because they
redacted all of it so well it is
interesting I had a long conversation
with the staff about there are these
very strict rules about depositions that
are conducted by the House of
Representatives if you have a deposition
if you'd oppose somebody you can only
deposed chairman and the ranking member
present you know hard that is it would
be I mean I would be dead and gone five
lifetimes before they got through so
what they're doing is they're doing
interviews now it is a felony to lie to
in the during the course of a federal
investigation whether it is to an agency
or two member of Congress so they are
tantamount to being
underoath they can be prosecuted but
then come back to this the big
difficulty is you've got Eric Holder as
the head of the Justice Department his
remember when the president announced on
May fifteenth you know I'm really mad
about this scandal this is really
terrible i'm going to have FBI Derek
Lord is going to investigate really
you'd think they might have called me by
now you'd think they might have called
one of my clients by now there we have
seen no evidence of any FBI
investigation to try to get to the
bottom of this well they were
johnny-on-the-spot to interview
Catherine Engelbrecht about who was
attending her meetings from the from the
domestic terrorism unit I might add
which tells you they consider the Tea
Party movement to be terrorists they do
and they have made that pretty clear but
you know look I don't disagree with you
I think that one of the things we ought
to do is we got to say that IRS
employees not allow to be allowed to
join a union I don't think we should
have Union in that IRS I mean they will
somehow we have to find a way to shrink
the size of this agency that's what I
keep saying to the members on the hill
as you know look this is everything this
is showing the American people that when
we talk about shrinking the size of
government we're not just talking about
throwing you know pushing granny over
the cliff in her wheelchair we're
talking about shrinking the size of an
agency that is a threat to the civil
liberties of every American and you know
but I think one of the things we have to
do I agree with you we got to find get
to the bottom of the role of the unions
in this yes yes
i Ken mizugi in a Washington Post column
you suggested that withdrawing Tom
Perez's nomination I did to labor which
I thought was really brilliant it didn't
happen no alas but two questions he will
head up the office of the Federal
contract compliance and so one question
would be the possible abuse of civil
rights enforcement along the lines of
what's going on in the IRS and the other
thing is why don't you think the
Republicans made as an objection to
Perez the virtual criminalization of
using criminal background checks in
employment well those are really good
questions you know I get frustrated with
our guys I know they mean well but they
sometimes strike me is not very
strategic and they the the argument that
they made about Perez they got all we
talk tom perez us just for those of you
who don't know who he is he was the head
of the Civil Rights Division at the
Department of Justice and he just was
confirmed in that deal a couple weeks
ago as the Secretary of Labor and in
February of this year the inspector
general of the Justice Department issued
a report saying that under Tom Perez and
the department of civil rights of the
civil rights of the Justice Department
that decisions were being made based on
on the basis of philosophy political
philosophy and ideology rather than on
the based on the law so he just got
promoted and then the guy and you know
they made a valiant fight sort of
against him but they decided to focus on
a deal that a really sick thing that he
had done in with the city of st. Paul
but they did not focus on a lot of the
things that I thought they should have
focused on and that's one of them and
you know you make a very good point this
whole fed
contracting issue remember what are one
of the things that the Obama
administration proposed not long after
citizens united was that anybody who
wanted a federal contract would have to
tell who they'd made political
contributions to as a means of quote
disclosure let me tell you you need to
understand when people when they when
the left talks about disclosure they are
not talking about transparency they are
looking for a target list that both
friends and enemies so it's you know Tom
Perez worries me a lot it was he was
awful where he was he's going to be
awful where he is now yes well first off
as a resident of Cincinnati I would like
to thank you for putting Torres the myth
that this is all my city's fault it's
been really annoying to me and I
honestly think it's tarnished the places
image so thank you for that um that's a
good point the Chamber of Commerce
thought of you know come out and say
something but my question is one of the
objection nerves defended the
Constitution against from the
anti-federalist was the possibility for
the mission sort of machinery the
federal government to be put to use
against political opponents especially
during election times and I think the
arguments that they made were pretty
convincing but do you think that the the
targeting that we saw and continue to
see especially as it's ramped up in the
wake of the twenty twelve election and
as is starting to emerge actually did
have a definite impact on those
organizations ability to advocate for
the causes they wanted do you think that
represents an instance of that sort of
machinery being put to use and if so how
do you stop a machine that sort of seems
to operate itself and as the way that
the bureaucracy does from from doing
that when it's sort of its own creature
you know you ask a really important and
very fundamental question at which
really I think
to something that conservatives and
grassroots citizens all over the country
are asking is how do we get control back
of our government because right now it
seems that the government is out of
control and we send these great young
great new people to Congress and they
seem unable to do something to do
anything about it but you have to
remember is that all of the all of this
has been codified over 80 80 plus years
I mean that basically the modern federal
government has been built over almost a
century by people who fundamentally
disagree with us and so when we send
people to Washington and to Congress
we're sending people who are just trying
to put their fingers in the dike and I
don't think that we've ever stopped as a
you know the Republican Party is
hopeless I mean they just make me crazy
but we have not been strategic in saying
what do we have to do to pull the props
out and to start unwinding some of these
things that have built up for literally
almost a century and you don't you just
this week i was telling dr. Bob you know
I this week the house is doing the stop
government abuse week so guess what to
have any of you heard of that and they
have about I don't know 30 different
pieces of legislation and they're going
to pass all these things and then
they're going to go home and no one will
know and and there it's small ball it's
a small ball you know pick two or three
things and talk about it for a month or
six weeks they think if they do
something in one of those chambers that
we all know and if you don't know who
you so you try to talk about that what
we passed that three weeks ago really
well you know what I have a life to live
I don't actually don't know if you don't
do a better job of telling us so look I
mean I think that you ask the
fundamental question and I i will tell
you you go back and read the
anti-federalists I don't want to say
this but I will an awful
one of the things they worried about
have come to pass an awful lot of the
things that anti-federalists said if you
do this this is what will happen has
happened so how do we unwind that it's
not going to be easy but we have to
rebalance it we just have to to save our
country and we have time for one more
question okay how about over there thank
you pastor and I wonder if you have any
hope that the i guess the nearest IG is
the Treasury Department IG that anything
positive will come out of their of their
efforts well I look I mean I think that
Russell George gets a lot of credit for
the extent of I mean of the the fallout
from his report already now he's going
to look at the auditing he's going to
look into your case and other cases and
I think that you know one of the things
that's happened is that the Democrats on
the committee's are realizing that he is
making headway and now they're trying to
discredit him you know so they said you
know we you didn't you didn't talk about
the targeting of progressive groups he
said well we actually did we looked at
the we looked exactly at that and we
looked at the statistical analysis and
based on the random sampling that we
took the statistical analysis is that
about thirty percent of progressive
groups groups that said progressive or
progress in their name were pulled
looked at and then released back into
the stream but but there I think they're
going to do everything they can to try
to discredit him too because they see
that he is actually moving forward on a
number of fronts and making some
progress but remember this when he
conducted that investigation which took
a year at more than a year the
supervisor from the exempt organizations
unit was sitting in on all the meetings
and he had no documents it was all just
conversation interviews he had no emails
no memoranda
none of that and so that is one of the
things that the congressional committees
are trying to get here that are the
memoranda and the documentation that
were not provided to the inspector
general but we just have to be vigilant
as always talk to your members and thank
you all for your interest and for coming
appreciate it